[Applause]
jassem and l we gather all the
young people of belgium in several cities
because we find that he founded
the action vis-à-vis global
warming and we are here today in
decline and to do  shake things up
we have a group of students we are new
we set up an association called
voice of bah oury which fights against
single-use plastic for me it
's not too late I don't want
tomorrow  'there's more plastic and
fish in the water that there are
policies that need to move but
we are activists at the
individual level we are convinced that things can
also happen
today at great attenberg which is
relou support us it's really an
icon of youth this spokesperson
for our
movement buses to something is happening
the new generation will reinvent the
system and no it's not care bears but
in brussels
it's  the headquarters of the sbm google we
started  with manuela the challenge of
banning plastic straws in
brussels the passages of the vast
excavations suddenly we found the
washable reusable stainless steel straw it has become
a very trendy object whose
restaurant
honeywell west and we come to
know a little about straws  the
feedback they provided to you the customers are
delighted with what is happening at the moment
it is in the country they like it when
you are young that you are from sweden from
belgium from france from italy there is a
thing we have in common is that we
were educated in relatively the same
way and this ecological question at the
level of
europe is very present
now there is the european union which
has just passed a law wanted very very
heavy that bans mulch and all
single-use plastic from
2020 so for me the European Union
is above all a facilitator
but all the ideas come from
young people on lens la g we try to
share things that we do  p  for
example this morning's plugin and we
also want to show that we are also
young people who don't always fall into
the stereotype we have green people
[Music]
I consider myself without common sense as
a pauline taker we really  since
there is a lot to do
in ecology which is economically and
financially very interesting and therefore
the step and it's just the beginning
local dreams of developing other
products
[Music]
[Applause]